so implicit bias training Keith let me
ask you what do you think of the
training oh it's pretty interesting at
first I wasn't sure if I was gonna like
it or not hmm
so I came here apprehensive about it and
then the instructors being retired
police officers kind of knew that going
in so talking to them about it actually
ended up being pretty entertaining so
what do you think you were learning in
this course they trained us thoroughly
and professionally how to conduct
ourselves and how we interact with the
communities and how we serve them so I
believe that the class just reinforces
how we come upon different six different
experiences in the community the issues
that we face as police officers how are
we handling and helping the communities
but do you think do you think there is
some validity to what people and say the
black lives matter movement have said
about police officers is there something
there that gives them the reason to
think that perhaps there is some bias
within police departments regarding
black lives matter it's sort of just
taking you know small-scale incidents
with police departments and blowing them
out of proportion you often have to make
split-second decisions how do you not
generalize how do you not profile when
it's a split-second decision well I'm
training I mean we thought what our
training is life experiences that we
have as individuals we can't look at
someone just because they may have a
certain type of clothing on or they may
look a certain way or they may be a
certain gender we don't look at
individuals in that kind of capacity we
have to assess the circumstances based
off of our training and which is the
pretty thorough and handle the situation
appropriately